hey folks Chris waters here at PAX East
feeling slightly bruised and battered
after getting brutally destroyed by my
colleague Sean McGinnis I mean I
wouldn't say brutally I would say
thoroughly and without any question
whatsoever but I feel like context is
important here I destroyed you within
evolve that's right you were playing the
Goliath monster I'm sure your folks have
seen pictures of the towering statue
they have down there and that's actually
we're gonna talk about in this video
because there's been some changes to the
ability system that you got to get into
Sean and clearly it worked out all right
for you it worked out pretty well for me
so we actually played evolved like a
couple months ago two or three months
ago had a good time with it they've
tweaked the way that skills work for
Goliath specifically so previously at
the beginning of a match you would
choose a skill right so maybe that's you
pick up a giant rock and throw it or you
breathe fire or you do like a really
fast dash attack you choose one you have
that at the beginning and then you
evolve a couple times throughout the
match and unlock new skills now it's a
little bit different you're still
unlocking skills but there's a skill
point system so there's tiers so let you
start with three skill points at the
beginning of a match so I can do all
three into Rock smash if I'm really
confident in my abilities or I can
spread it out a little bit more do like
rock smash fire-breathing - and that's
kind of what I did and that's what ended
up working out so well for me is that it
let me kind of like spread the strategy
around a little bit kind of like play it
safe at the beginning and then over the
first like five or six minutes of the
match once I figure out what's really
working for me then I'm dumping skill
points into that and in my case it was
the rock smash so it takes your normal
large rock that you rip up out of the
ground into like a huge fiery boulder
yes and which like explodes with this
area damage and knocks the hunters off
on their butts
and that was nasty cuz it gave you this
ranged attack and then you could kind of
close in or like I was playing the medic
so I was trying to heal and there was
more than a few times that you were kind
of mauling a dude I was healing them and
you like followed the green line back
and beam me with a rock and all of a
sudden chaos is breaking loose and
you're really sort of
growing us but the fact that you can now
distribute those skill points between
skills either to make one skill like
really damaging right from the get-go
spread it around a little bit gives you
a little more strategic flexibility yeah
absolutely it kind of lets you just
decide like where you're gonna funnel
your tactics right am I going to am I
gonna focus on that rock smash ability
and just really rely on those like
high-risk high-reward attacks or am I
going to spread them around because the
thing is like we're talking to one of
the producers of the game and he
mentioned the fact that you can chain
those abilities together so you do one
you do the fire breathing you do the
rock smash you do the charge and by the
time you do that third one the cooldown
on your first one has ended and then you
can just keep going back and forth oh
but those are all level one abilities
and no one of them is really all that
devastating it's when you get that level
three ability that's when like chaos
happens yeah but then again you know if
you have level three rock smash for
example in another example he gave us
him and a team of hunters recognize that
the Goliath had put so many points into
the rock smash so they closed in on the
monster which kind of seems
counterintuitive like why do I want to
get close to the joining with claws and
teeth and trying to kill me but because
he didn't have the fire-breathing
ability didn't have the leap smash
wasn't as versatile close range and the
hunters were able to take him down in
that situation so it's sort of all
depends on your play style and you know
you look at the game and you think for
hunt for different hunters that's
clearly four different play styles right
there yeah but then you have the monster
there's way more than just one way to
play the monster and that's what makes
each match feel so different they're
just showing off these abilities here at
PAX East there's a lot more stuff in the
can we haven't seen other monsters yet
we haven't seen other hunter types yet
we haven't seen other maps yet all that
stuff is coming evolve is slated to come
out this fall for the Xbox one the ps4
and the PC so we're certainly gonna have
a lot more to tell you in the coming
months stay tuned the game spot for that
and all weekend we're covering PAX East
we've got tons of indie games big games
games of all sizes we're gonna be
talking about stick around